hi I'm Eric Voss and we are also excited
about the Game of Thrones series finale
eight seasons of action have built to a
final episode that we will be talking
about for a long time I'm hard at work
right now on several Game of Thrones
videos including our episode 5 breakdown
but I wanted to tell you about a special
new mark stars live event that we are
going to be hosting in New York City for
the finale we will be in the hotel Red
Lion in Brooklyn this Sunday May 19th we
will be watching the final episode in
doing a live taping and you can join us
this is going to be a super fun event
where you can celebrate with us and
fellow Game of Thrones fans or you know
drown your sorrows with friends when the
show breaks your heart we will be
answering questions from the audience
we're going to have a costume contest in
a trivia contest with some pretty nice
prizes for both there will be free food
in drinks because you know watching
brand sit silently always makes me
hungry and thirsty
New York was the top request in a recent
Twitter poll for a live taping location
and we're just so pumped to get to meet
some of our East Coast fans for tickets
and more information about the event
check out the ticket link in the
description below there is also a
discount code for 25% off your stay at
the hotel Red Lion if you want to stay
that night we were just so excited for
this event and we hope to see some of
you there and maybe we can hit the dance
floor too some rains of castamere know
what too soon yeah too soon